entre deux bombardements anna profite
d'une accalmie pour mettre en place une
cuisine de fortune
mais le répit est de courte durée
il y à des tirs tout le temps et des
éclats d'obus qui volent partout on peut
entendre depuis le sous sol alors on
s'enferme autant que possible et on
reste assis
27 personnes vivent encore ici sans eau
ni gaz ni électricité
un quotidien rythmé par les
déflagrations régulière aux alentours
bien sûr que c'est dangereux
et de l'autre côté de la rue la maison a
été complètement détruite en obus a volé
dans une chambre est le premier et le
deuxième étage ont été détruits dans le
sous sol de l'immeuble sont réfugiés
principalement des personnes âgées
à l'abri des bombes mais pas du bruit
elles ne savent pas combien de temps
elles pourront tenir
quand les tirs deviennent vraiment fort
et que tout le monde se met à trembler
on s'assoit tous en cercle on prend
notre tête à demain et on commence a
pris au coin de la rue un char ukrainien
s'avance à grande vitesse
le quartier est désert seul cet homme a
pris le risque de s'exposer pour ramener
son cheval chez lui
depuis plusieurs jours la ville de
severodonezk que subit un siège
ininterrompue elle constitue l'une des
dernières poches de résistance
ukrainienne dans le donbass
tarn coin c'est le faire
le bombardement de severodonetsk elles
brutale et dénuée de sens c'est vrai il
ya eu 12 morts et des dizaines de
blessés en une seule journée
[Musique]
dans l'autre camp l'armée russe affirme
qu'elle continuera d'attaquer jusqu'à ce
que la ville tombe en dépit du nombre de
victimes parmi les civils